do you remember the days when there was
a demo for nearly every single game well
I definitely do and that's why I'm
excited about the news of a prey demo
hitting a week before the full game's
launch I met in this game spot news
update is ready for some sci-fi monsters
and guns praised opening our demo is
headed to ps4 and xbox one on April 27
that's more than a whole week before the
game's official launch however if you
were hoping to try it out on pc then it
seems like you're out of luck bethesda
made no mention of a pc demo in its
press release and the trailer only
featured logos for the console platforms
now that's really disappointing because
I play the vast majority of my games on
PC and while we have no way of knowing
that this spells bad news for the pc
version it doesn't give me much
confidence anyway if you want to know
how the pc version runs then make sure
to LIKE and subscribe so we can keep you
updated on everything pray pray hits the
ps4 xbox one and pc on May 5th as for
other demos Bethesda recently released a
trial for dishonored to the demo
features its first three chapters which
to be honest is a pretty significant
chunk of the game however if you're
looking for more sci-fi action and
horror then check out our feature on
prey and how it can scare you with a
trash can
[Music]